the far right obsession with Fitness is
going digital
tell me that's not crazy wait the far
right so I I retweeted it and I put
something at the top I said does the
opposite also me go a little lower does
the opposite also mean it's true the far
left's Obsession would be and fat and
lazy is going digital ironically yes
yeah so if you work at even Joe said
wait a minute now if I work out I'm a
right wink right yeah all right
yeah like by the way let's say if they
are saying that okay so so moving
forward every time I see somebody who is
willing to take the time to work out
their disciplined with their diet they
go to the gym three four times they're
detailed with you know chest and back
and shoulders and triceps or bison tries
and legs and they're very disciplined
with all that stuff that's a right wing
well guess what you know you know what
the Republicans should do they should
use this and say guess what yeah yeah we
are we like to say hello lean into it
you guys like vaccines we like to work
out yeah you guys like to use like even
Peter Hotel say do you work here no not
really what do you yeah I eat a lot of
junk food don't you think that's bad
food do you take vitamins Now Vitamins
don't really work you know I only take
vaccines really yeah well they're
talking about studies about this if you
are a man and you go to the gym and you
work out and you have higher
testosterone you are more likely to be
right wing then correct wing and I don't
think it's a mystery as to why because a
lot of the I guess mentality that would
lead to someone going to the gym
self-improvement personal response
responsibility discipline those are more
inherently conservative than socialists
not to mention just the I guess you know
if you go to the gym your testosterone
levels are going to be higher because
you're exercising and being having a
higher testosterone level is more
commonly associated with right-wing
values because it's like you're you're
less effeminate less willing to nurture
redistribute all those so you're saying
most steroids dealers are Republicans
[Laughter]
yeah well just look at the UFC the UFC I
mean I'm not going to say everyone who's
a pro fighter is going to be Republican
or right-wing but that is one of the few
Sports where I think you see a lot a lot
of even if they're not openly we like I
know for a fact that a lot of people in
that sphere professional fighting they
are conservative they do lean right oh
when they see Trump they like a fighter
this past weekend something out of the
ring and was like Mr Trump like I love
you but it's not well I didn't know that
going to the gym like yeah well I'm a
racist Jesus that's right it's so absurd
there are to to confirm what you're
saying there have been studies out there
that attribute being a little bit more
attractive to being a little bit more
conservative right-wing free thinking
because it comes down to
personal accountability right and that's
really what it comes down to there's
multiple studies like this but this to
me I'd like to see the studies they get
where it just seems [__] on the
surface because I know so many people
left right center up down gay straight
who just are want to look good and take
care of themselves I mean I live in
Miami and South Beach you have no idea
how many gay guys are out there looking
[__] they look great no I mean I'm
not into that thing but whatever
whatever great but it's it's just so
absurd so I I fully agree with Pat
if you're on the GOP embrace the hell
out of this the left are just fat sloppy
lazy losers wait uh relying on vaccines
and you're taking personal
accountability and personal
responsibility for your health if you're
on the right
it's a bad look for yeah for MSNBC to
write that I I would run with it I'm
telling you if I'm on the other side I'm
on a run even MSNBC says you know we're
in shape we have the right habits and
the other side doesn't so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]